family is outraged over a social media
post supposedly shared by an assistant
principal at cimarron high school it
states that those who are unmasked or
unvaccinated should perish kate houston
live in the newsroom tonight with why
one parent is taking this personally
kate yes well this is the social media
post in question and it is directed at
those who are unvaccinated and at one
point in part it says that if you are
not taking proactive measures we hope
you catch it and die quickly hashtag
sorry not sorry one father tells me that
a student at cimarron high school his
daughter saw that post as he's battling
covet 19 in the hospital i'm stuck i
can't do anything i'm a big guy and i
can't even get out of bed without help
vincent justina tested positive for
covid19 on saturday and is now battling
bilateral pneumonia his daughter a
cimarron high school student as well as
his stepson also positive they're
worried to sick and it's just it's a sad
situation justina and his daughter are
not vaccinated he says she sent him the
post after the school was notified of
her positive case i think it's
absolutely unprofessional my daughter's
at home worried about her daddy and
she's going to put that out on social
media on wednesday an email was sent to
cimarron memorial high school families
it states in part the district is aware
of a social media post made by a staff
member and is working to address the
situation justina says there needs to be
more consequences the school obviously
needs to do some sort of apologizing not
just a little email like oh i'm sorry
she said this we dealt with it no i need
to see it through to the end
justina says he took the post personally
due to the timing and his vaccination
status he's now heard from both sides on
whether or not to get the vaccine and he
doesn't wish this on anyone if you have
asked me that two weeks ago i would have
said absolutely not
it's my body it's my choice
it's just because of all the pain and
everything in the drugs and everything
they're pumping into me
and it's just it's not comfortable i
would do anything right now to not have
to go through this
well hundreds of people are now
expressing their outrage through a
change.org petition calling for the
assistant principal to be terminated now
i did reach out to the clark county
school district for answers both by
calling them emailing them and asking
about the employment status of that
assistant principal i am awaiting
answers on that reporting live kate
houston 8 news now